there's a very good chance you've never
even heard of this guy this is Mansa
Musa the richest man in history Mana
Musa was a devout Muslim meaning much
like today it was his solemn duty to
undertake the Harge pilgrimage to Mecca
at least once in his lifetime the
pilgrimage that ensued from Mali to the
Arabian Peninsula is one of the most
remarkable Journeys ever made by a human
being what I actually mean is 60,000 men
in women 100 elephants 80 camels a
personal guard of 500 highly trained
Warriors and enough food water and
animals to eat for everyone Mana Musa
reserved a little extra cash to treat
himself along the way in this case it
was
21,000 kg of solid gold